[Music]
i shall start with free air television
commercial television especially united
states
now think about
they were a very strange kind of thing
of good because they could not be
commodified
they were more like a sunset
how can you make people pay for it
so what happened was their broadcast was
used
to magnetize the attention of the
audience before selling the attention of
the audience to advertisers
when there is a will
there is a capitalist way of
commodifying things
and then advertisers use the access
to people's arrested attention
to do something quite audacious
to enlist emotions
which had escaped commodification so far
to the task of deepening commodification
let me give you an example because that
sounds a bit complicated it isn't really
i don't know how many of you have
watched
that great splendid serial mad men
with don draper being the archetypal
brilliant advertiser
at the heart of madman
there was this scene when he's coaching
his protege a young woman called peggy
on how to think of a chocolate bar a
hershey bar
draper caught the spirit of the times
when he said to her
peggy
you don't buy a hershey bar for a couple
of ounces of chocolate and i'm quoting
here you buy it to recapture the feeling
of being loved the feeling that you knew
when your dad brought you one for mowing
the lawn
so this is it it's the co-modification
of nostalgia the nostalgia that was
never commodified is being used
by draper okay in order
to hyper commodify
a chocolate bar
that was a turning point of capitalism
draper i mean the fictional the person
who's
writing the draper role was putting her
or his finger on a fundamental mutation
in the dna of capitalism
efficiently manufacturing things that
people craved that people already craved
was no longer enough
with the rise of the big conglomerates
in the 1920s 30s and especially after
the second world war
the rise of what john kenneth galbraith
that wonderful economist of the 1950s
60s 70s and 80s he described
that
variety of capitalism that emerged from
the rise of the conglomerates especially
after the second world war
with the heavy role of government in
regulating the global economy with
bretton woods and so on he called it the
techno structure
what changed with the techno structure
was
that
simply manufacturing things was not
enough
the point of manufacturing was not to
satiate existing needs
manufacturing had become so
mass-produced
so efficient
that
manufacturing commodities had to go hand
in hand with manufacturing the desire
for commodities now
we are all familiar with
how commercial television works
this is
the linchpin
between the technostructure's capacity
to produce all sorts of commodities and
its capacity to manufacture our desire
for those commodities
then
once the internet
which had begun life
as a plant system came out of
the military and the academic market
the universities
once however it was
cannibalized it was taken over by
commercial conglomerates the internet
changed the principles of advertised
of advertising it moved them
into something quite different
instead of having don draper or the
draperies of the world the advertisers
coming up with concepts for commodifying
our nostalgia in order to recommodify
commodities
the internet allowed for the creation of
algorithmic systems permitting
person-specific targeting of
advertisements
that television could not support we're
all familiar with the kind of
person specific
algorithmic based
target
advertising targeting of google or
facebook of tick tock and so on now at
first the first algorithms what they did
was something quite straightforward they
identified clusters of users
people with similar tastes with similar
similar search patterns in google in the
google engine similar preferences
those algorithms grouped them together
to complete their searches to make them
more efficient to suggest books records
to them to us
films
but then
came a major breakthrough at some point
the algorithms ceased to be passive
once algorithms could evaluate their own
performance
they the algorithms began to behave like
agents
they began to monitor and react to the
outcomes of their own actions
at that point they began not only to
affect the people they surveyed
but additionally to affect themselves
by the way people were affected by them
before we knew it
the task of instilling desires in our
soul was taken from the don drapers and
the peggies
of madmen from human beings
running the advertising industry
and that task was now handed over to the
alexas and to the series to all those
talking algorithms whether you have an
iphone
an amazon alexa google assistant
whatever
now those who question
how real the threat of artificial
intelligence is
to white collar jobs should ask
themselves
what exactly does alexa or siri do
ostensibly alexa is a home-based
mechanical servant
in reality alexa or siri or google
assistant or any of those assistants
they are just the front end of a
gigantic artificial intelligence
cloud-based
network
that millions of us if not billions of
us
are training
several
billion
times every second
as we chat on the phone
or move and do things while carrying our
mobile phone
the system this cloud-based algorithmic
system learns our preferences and habits
and as it gets to know us it develops an
uncanny capacity to surprise us with
good recommendations about books and so
on
even with ideas that intrigue us
before we realize it the system has
acquired substantial powers to guide our
choices effectively to command us
with cloud-based alexa-like devices or
applications in the role once occupied
by human beings like don draper
we find ourselves the most dialectical
of infinite regresses
think of what it is that we do
in real time real time perpetually
we train the algorithm so the algorithm
knows how to train us
to do the things that in the interest of
the owners
and the more we do this
the faster the algorithm learns how to
help us train the algorithm to train us
to train the algorithm to train us to
train the algorithm to train us and so
on and so forth
the owners of this type of algorithmic
cloud-based dialectical command capital
or i shall call it for short command
capital
the owners of this command capital
have the automated power to commanders
to do things of enormous financial
benefit to themselves
now with such special powers
i do believe that
the owners of substantial amounts of
this command capital need to be called
something
other than capitalists than traditional
capitalists
allow me to coin a term
i'm going to call them cloud lists
from the cloud where the algorithmic
command capital that they own and which
gives them so
tremendous power over the rest of
humanity that's where it lives on the
cloud so i shall call them the
cloudellis
now how how
are they different substantially
different
to the owners of a traditional
advertising firm
like
that featured in madmen
a firm whose ads
back then in the 50s and 60s were also
convincing us to buy things that we
neither needed nor wanted
is there a substantial difference
well think about it
the advertising firms of yesteryear
styling cooper and associates i believe
was the one the fictional one in madman
what they did was they sold services to
the corporations
trying to sell us things
however glamorous or inspired their
employees might have been
they were
traditional
service sector workers
highly paid you know usually more drunk
than usual
or than other workers but they were
traditional service sector workers in
contrast
in contrast the cloudy lists
who own the command capital
to begin with they don't have to have
employees these are algorithmic
cloud-based bits of software
and the hardware that allows them this
infinite regress between our training
them and them training us
this
command capital as i call as i call it
gives
its owners
whom i just called the clouderalists
two
very new and very interesting kinds of
power
the first is the power that cloudelists
have
to extract huge rents
from manufacturers
in other words from other capitalists
from manufacturers whose stuff they
persuade as the cloudless or their
command capital persuades us to buy
because the same command capital
that makes us
want the stuff
is the foundation of the platforms like
amazon.com
where those purchases take place it is
as if don draper or his advertising
agency were to take over the markets
where the wares don draper advertises
are sold
this is big this is not just a mere
extension of a service market the
advertiser is not just selling
through command capital
others
goods but it actually owns
the market or has taken over and
replaced
the market
with a platform which is the same
algorithmic cloud-based
complex
that creates
the need in our soul for the staff and
sells it to us
even though the owner of that command
capital does not own the manufacturing
progress uh process
now if you look at it through this prism
cloudera lists are turning
conventional capitalists into a new
vassal class
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas